[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
the drive to get more disadvantaged
youngsters into work I'll be speaking
with Charles Woodburn chairman of
movement to work and chief executive of
course of BAE Systems
the prime minister to expand on his
plans for all children to study maths
until they're 18.
a major Summit on the future of Finance
kicks off in London but has the collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank dented confidence
a rally in cryptocurrencies so far this
year but challenges remain I'll be
speaking with the chief executive of the
crypto Exchange coinbase
flower we have a liquid power you know
haligured and Dusty power
and the Argentinian Ambassador on his
country's secret weapon as it marks
World Malbec day
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live and
now of business and economic news from
the Heart of the City well plenty of
business used to come with a pat program
to bring you but we're just going to
briefly uh listen to the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak who's giving this speech on
his approach to education and the
importance of math that follows his call
for all children to study maths in some
form until they're 18. we're just going
to listen in briefly listening to this
we'll want to know what that means for
our children today so let me tell you
we're in the process of making maths
more accessible building our children's
confidence so that they don't fear maths
we're creating more sector specific
content that can excite young people
about the relevance of mass for the
careers that they aspire to to help
teachers bring math to life in the
classroom from building sets for school
plays to calculating the angles of free
kicks or the speed of a Formula One car
we're extending our math hubs unique
Partnerships of expert schools that
support math teaching and we're
strengthening maths in primary schools
including with a new fully funded
professional qualification for those
that are teaching it
but we also need to address well there
we go we'll leave that uh Speech there
if you want to watch uh more of Richie
sunax speech scan the QR code on the
screen right now to head to our politics
hub
now today sees the start of the innovate
Finance Global Summit a get-together of
major Banks Regulators fintechs policy
makers and investors for a series of
discussions on the future of finance and
the banking sector well they meet in the
aftermath of the recent failure of
Silicon Valley Bank with which many
fintechs banked I asked Janine Hertz the
chief executive of innovate Finance
whether silicon Valley's bank's failure
had changed the mood in the sector I
think the Silicon Valley Bank scenario
especially here in the UK is really
interesting because the speed at which
svb UK was dealt with and the quick and
Rapid sale of svuk to HSBC I think was a
real Testament of this government's
commitment to support the fintech
industry but it was also a great example
of where we see collaboration between
industry government and Regulators
making positive change and it's that
collaboration that I think truly sets
the UK apart from all of our Global
peers on the international stage that's
very encouraging to hear but what about
sentiment towards London in particular
among fintechs right now I mean I'm
picking up a bit of a drum beat that
that Paris is now the place to be oh
well actually London and the UK more
broadly is definitely the place to be we
saw in 2022 and this is despite economic
turbulence more than 12.5 billion US
Dollars invested into the UK fintech
ecosystem that's second in the world
only to the United States and we're
actually ahead of the next 13 European
countries behind combined
what about the Venture Capital sector
right now clearly it's a tougher funding
environment than it has been in recent
years are you still seeing fintechs able
to raise Capital where they need to we
are and actually it is of course there
is a turbulent period in terms of
economics at the moment but the numbers
for 2022 more investment than ever
before came into UK fintech with the
exception of 2021 and we do see 201
essentially as anomaly of a year so
we're still seeing very high levels of
investment coming in and one of the
other big uh events that's taken place
over the last six months or so was the
failure of FTX the crypto exchange what
are you hearing about crypto right now
absolutely I think where we stand at
innovate finance and with our members is
there's a real need to ensure proactive
regulation and ensure that we are at the
Forefront of Regulation more broadly and
that also applies to the crypto space
but more broadly on the fintech level uh
overall as well and those are one of the
themes we'll be looking at in our
innovate Finance Global Summit which is
taking place today and tomorrow and
throughout UK fintech week as well are
people thinking more broadly about the
kind of applications that crypto might
be used for now it's less about
cryptocurrency itself and more about the
blockchain technology underpinning it
absolutely and there is also a lot of
dialogue around things like Central Bank
digital currencies and the role of
crypto and digital assets and digital
Finance especially in terms of looking
at how we can make a better Financial
Services System for everyone and make it
more equal and more democratic and what
about the the macro backdrop right now
obviously we're still in a in a rate
tightening environment is that affecting
the way that fintechs are approaching
their work right now are they more
focused on on profitable growth rather
than just say growth per se one of the
most exciting areas that we're seeing
fintech really progress is this
opportunity to create a more equal
Financial Services sector so so many
fintechs right now are working on
creating solutions that are helping
individuals that are helping smes better
manage their finances better understand
their finances grow their money and
really survive during this cost of
living crisis you were quite
complementary about the UK government
just now do you think that the
regulatory environment in this country
could do with improving is it's as good
as it gets for fintechs I do think one
of the reasons we have been and continue
to be such a leader in fintech is
because we've historically always had a
very proactive regulator so in the light
of the FCA but also the pra it's
absolutely critical that we continue to
have that forward-thinking regulation
and that proactive regulation both to
protect the consumer but also to really
enable the consumer to benefit from some
of these great Technologies we're seeing
some other business news stories for you
now and the advertising magnets of
Martin Sorrel one of the UK's best known
business figures said this morning that
he had recently received Keyhole surgery
to remove a tumor sir Martin who built
wpp into the world's biggest advertising
company and who has since set up a new
advertising and marketing group S4
Capital said he'd made an excellent
recovery from the surgery in February
but that he had been advised to have
preventative treatment over coming
months
the oil field services and engineering
company John Wood Group said this
morning it had agreed to open
negotiations with the U.S private Equity
Firm trying to buy it wood which employs
35 000 people around the world said
Apollo's latest approach for it its
fifth valued it at 1.66 billion pounds
it said that as a result it decided to
engage with Apollo and open its books
wood said that Apollo had told it that
it values the skills and capabilities of
woods employees and believes the company
is well positioned in its market and at
the Forefront of the energy transition
and Industrial decarbonization
the payments provide a network
International said this morning it has
received a takeover proposal from a
private Equity Consortium that values it
at 2.06 billion pounds the approach
comes from CVC capital and Francisco
Partners well Matt Network which is
based in Dubai enables digital payments
for merchants across the Middle East and
Africa when it floated on the London
Stock Market in April 2019 it was the
UK's biggest Tech flotation for four
years but its share prices failed to
recover since it was hit in 2020 by
Links between one of its African
subsidiaries and the Crash German
payments company wirecard
Rovio The Finnish maker of the Angry
Birds mobile game has received a
takeover bid from the Japanese games
publisher Sega Sammy valuing it at 706
million euros the approach comes weeks
after the Israeli company platika sought
to buy Rovio for 683 million euros well
Angry Birds was the world's first game
to be downloaded more than one billion
times and was a Trailblazer when
smartphones were still to be widely used
but Rovio failed to build on its success
although it did trade profitably during
2022.
now Argentina is marking the 13th annual
World Malbec Day celebrating one of its
biggest exports the UK is Argentina's
second biggest market for wine after the
United States with experts with exports
worth almost 150 million dollars per
year well I've been speaking to Javier
Figueroa he's the Argentinian Ambassador
about what he describes as his country's
secret weapon and why he believes the UK
and Argentinian economies complement
each other
Argentina is a big a big product as a
supporter and you know wine in general
you know is a big chunk of our exports
and particularly United Kingdom is our
second Market we support here around
147 million dollars or so which is a
record you know I'm a big chunk of this
is Malbec you know and you know my leg
is a sort of a presentation car as a
country you know every country have a
sort of sub power we have a liquid power
you know a liquid and Dusty power for
many people who thought about Argentina
today thought about a football here or
wine and well Malbec day is the 17th of
April and there's a very specific reason
for that yes we decided to do that
because you know it's a way that is a
sort of how you put it after a global
toast you know for something that is
part of our world culture you know say
you think in Argentina you think the
beef and you know the perfect
companionship for a beef sandwich bag
you know and you know the malvect day is
a day that is sponsored by the ministry
of an Affairs and the Hawaiian
Corporation of Argentina there are many
many events around the world on the 17th
of April was the day that the first
Vines were brought to Argentina yeah
exactly it was you know that's a it was
a you know it's a merit it's a big
president of Argentina it's called
Domingo fantipotina saliento is one of
the big modernizer for Argentina and one
of this brightest idea parts of the
public education you know Argentina have
a public education and we are very proud
of that Argentina universities are free
you know and one of the things that the
Hebrew Malbec to Argentina to
particularly to the province of Mendoza
and on that moment it was a paradox
because when
Malbec is was not so popular in Europe
it began to be you know big things in
America
you just had a terrible drought in
Argentina that has presumably badly hit
a lot of the wine producers
yes yes it is it's a travel you know but
you know I think that the the industry
I think they have a way to overcome the
drugs they think that for example
Mendoza is a very dry area and I have a
very good system you know to irrigate
the Divine yards but indeed it's a
problem and it is a problem for
the whole Agro industry worldwide and
how are the producers grappling with
inflation which is obviously I mean We
complain about inflation in this country
but it's a real issue in Argentina right
now well let's see how we get used to
that you know and the most of the
producer of the you know the product of
the industry is going abroad you know
and uh you know they get used to the
instabilities of the economy you know I
think one of the way that Argentina
could you know overcome the economic
difficulties is growing experts and I
think wine is his uh the best for
example for the rest of the economy you
know the the I think the Argentine
industry modernized a lot in the last 20
years or so I first post abroad was here
in London and I remember on that time it
was very very difficult to find
Argentine wine in a restaurant or and
supermarket
and today it's everywhere
I think I might in saying though that
trade between the UK and Argentina has
just hit an all-time high in terms of
the volumes yes that is historical
records in our Commerce we explore more
than one billion Point almost five
million dollars and we import around one
third of that zoom and this is a record
you know it's in general Latin America
is not very important as a you know a
trading partner UK but Argentina is
important in this universe you know and
I think there is a lot of
uh way to improve that we don't have a
sailing in our
Commerce you know the last you know last
few months come our minister of energy
and there is really really huge interest
in oil and gas and you know and Mining
as well you know Argentina Argentina
Bolivia and Chile
this is a lithium triangle you know this
is the biggest you know reservoir of
lithium in the war and there is a sort
of frenzy regarding that how to develop
that and for us it's a challenge but
it's very very interesting though
because most people if they think about
Argentina's economy they do think of you
as an agricultural Powerhouse but the
fact that you're now exporting energy in
considerable volumes lithium potentially
as well the economy is going to be a lot
more diverse in years to come well
Argentina have a very diverse structure
we have a very strong industrial base
and
you know for example we export nuclear
reactors you know we explore nuclear
reactors to Australia to we are now
building one in the Netherlands and
Argentina produce and explore satellites
you know one of the the leading firms in
the war and microsatellites in an
Argentine firms and we have a you know
another big firm that is owned by the
one of the provinces of fonsitis that
produce you know this big nuclear
reactor for research and produce
Isotopes and these are things
you know they they you know the images
for Argentina many times me as an
ambassador so many Ambassador who had to
fight against stereotypes you know even
we argentinians we really don't know
what we country have for example many
people associate Argentina with meat but
we export more fish than meat since 20
30 years you know at uh or we explore
creative Industries you know that is uh
I think it's a big you know opportunity
that have my country to to develop
so how big can the the trade between the
UK and Argentina become well you know it
is you know I I think we can double that
figure that fear I think I'm pretty
optimistic on that is it possible to
double that fear you know because the
the economies are so complementary
you know I think that that is possible
to improve and one thing that we need to
improve is the the knowledge between
societies and because many times in
Argentina when you know if a bigger one
Argentina in the street and say how do
you think that is if UK and they have an
image of UK that is you know fixed in
the past and obviously you've just won
the World Cup I think people in England
have just about forgiven you for the
hand of God in 1999. but you have to
remember the second world of Maradona
that was great it was really really good
I remember you know you know I remember
I think it was a right in peace I think
it was a linear
like he wrote when Maradona died a
couple of years ago and he mentioned
that that well the first goal was you
know a little tricky but the the the
second role was you know a Masterwork
you know really really and yeah for us
it was a you know Imagine The Happenings
of Argentina when we won the the World
Cup you know would you like to see more
British tourists in Argentina
yes yes indeed one of the problems that
we have we don't have enough enough you
know Airlines today is only British
Airways who is flying a direct flight
but we are talking with another
companies to try to to gain more you
know more Air Links to Buenos Aires you
know I know that you know the British
tourists is you know per capita
the the tourists are the most spend
money in my country because it's a very
high-end uh tourist they go to fly fish
into Patagonia and you know they go to
you know the wine tasty into the Andes
and and yes we expect to have more you
know earlings unfortunately I expect
more British tourists as well
well the UK unemployment rate currently
stands at just 3.7 percent the
unemployment rate for 16 to 24 year olds
is 10.8 percent while the inactivity
rate that's those not in education
employment or training stands at 38.2
percent well the charity movement to
work was set up to tackle that State of
Affairs it seeks to help young people
not currently in education employment or
training step onto the career ladder by
working with UK employers to provide
quality jobs training and work placement
opportunities today marks its 10th
anniversary and it's hosting a CEO
conference to get more companies to
support its work well joining me now is
the Charities new chair Charles Woodburn
who is of course also chief executive of
BAE Systems Charles hey good morning to
you why do you think inactivity levels
are so high for this group
well it's been quite a challenging
period Ian and um as you said it is uh
something that we as businesses feel
very strongly about and anything we can
do to help get people uh into uh
workplaces give them the placement
opportunities which then hopefully will
lead to successful outcomes we as a
company have been one of the founding
members of movement to work I personally
have been involved since 2017 and we've
seen the people that have come through
movement to work I meet them as I go
around our UK businesses and see how
well they're doing they flourish with us
they come in typically for a placement
that becomes a bridge into an
apprenticeship and then from an
apprenticeship into the workplace and
high quality you know long-term
employment uh you know awaits at the end
of it so we have had a very strong
experience with movement to work a very
positive experience and uh you know part
of the reason I feel so passionate about
it is that I want to make sure that
other companies understand that there is
an answer to some of these Channel
challenges that these young people are
facing are employers doing a good enough
job in engaging with youth employment
programs
well I think there's quite a variety of
them and we certainly think that
movement to work Stands Tall within that
movement to work has actually offered a
hundred and sixty thousand opportunities
since it was founded uh 10 years ago and
more than half of those have led to
successful outcomes so you know that's a
very large number of people that have
that have used the opportunity and we're
very keen to make sure that you know
other companies are aware of the success
of movement to work uh aware of the
program the fact that it doesn't cost
anything to join movement to work uh you
know we support the young people they
get
um their transport and their lunches
paid for when they do a placement with
us and really to try and reduce the
barriers that some of these young people
face to find their way into a workplace
and ultimately a high quality long-term
employment at the end of it I mean your
company BAE Systems requires heavily on
very very highly skilled workers kind of
someone on the work placement really add
much value can can they pick up a lot in
a short space of time
well I think that the evidence is there
I mean we as a company through movement
to work have had 700 placements uh in
the last 10 years we're offering another
100 this year and as I've said already
as I go around our businesses I quite
often meet people that are very proud to
say that they started on a movement to
work placement and you know whilst the
placement itself is really a bridge into
an apprenticeship uh you know I always
think the placements they allow us as a
company to see you know how people work
in the place of work but equally they
allow those who are enjoying the
placement to see what we are like as an
employer and make a much more educated
decision so it is a you know first step
on a pathway uh but coming into our
Apprentice programs and as you know we
have a you know very strong Apprentice
program here in the UK we've increased
our Apprentice numbers but getting onto
an apprentice program then really is
then uh you know the first step or the
second step after the placement into
long-term employment to him now as we
speak the prime minister is giving a
speech on uh how he wants people to
carry on studying maths right up until
the age of 18. do you think that's a
good idea
well from our perspective you know we're
an engineering uh company uh at its
heart and uh stem or these numeracy
skills are indeed very important for us
so you know we firmly uh would support
uh you know more numeracy and a higher
standard coming out of of our schools
is the education system in this country
equipping young people sufficiently for
the kind of careers that the modern
economy is providing them with
but I think
there has been in the last
um you know handful of years I think a
more of an appreciation of what uh
apprenticeships can really offer and I
think that we've been as a company
trying to make sure that people
understand that there's always been this
sort of view at school age uh that that
you know The Graduate route was was in a
sense the only way into Quality
Employment and apprenticeships offer an
incredibly strong alternative
particularly at a time of cost of living
you know crises and some of the
challenges of inflation where you can
come into the work workplace
um you know in many cases people can
come through an apprenticeship and
indeed get a degree at the end of it not
all of them will will do that but
without debt and then um you know with
it with a job at the end of it and I
think that the more we can do as
employers to sort of demonstrate that
that is a not only just an alternative
but a very good alternative to the
standard graduate track I think it
behooves all of us to make sure or that
you know young people see the importance
of that see the significance of it and I
think you know for us as a company we do
a very good job in the places that are
close to our uh you know large centers
of employment but I think nationally
there's more we can do to raise the
profile of apprenticeships
and Charles while we have you uh there's
been a lot of talk in the recent past
about potentially the defense sector
being deprived of capital because some
investors won't invest on ESG grounds do
you feel that the war in Ukraine has
shifted sentiments among investors
towards the defense sector
I think it's fair to say in that it is
Shifting
um you know there is still some way to
go we've always maintained that you know
ESG and ESG considerations are important
but uh you know all of that requires the
foundation of defense and security and
without defense and security
um it's you know it's very hard to you
know give any uh
um credibility to the other uh aspects
of ESG so obviously I mean unfortunately
due to the uh conflict uh here in Europe
in the brutal invasion of Ukraine you
know I think that the the sort of the
the case for defense and security you
know has been uh more clearly made I
think you know within all of that it's
then important for us to show as an
employer the steps that we're taking to
be a good place to work that we look
after the environment The Net Zero
things that we're doing so they're all
important considerations but as a
foundation defense and security you know
has to be what modern democracies
freedom of speech all the things that we
take for granted are based upon
all right Charles we have to leave it
there really good to see you this
morning and bustle up with the events
thank you
thanks very much
still to come here only in King live
we'll have a look at how Global markets
are doing this Monday morning don't go
away
[Music]
that has happened within minutes and now
it's coming from both sides
moving this way
[Music]
only about half a mile from the Turkish
coast and it's evident that there's the
boat seriously overcrowded this is one
of the most severe viruses in the world
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Sky's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
Tennessee
that's it it got us then there's a lot
of action going on
a lot of still
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
[Music]
look at her arms I can put my entire
hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain World
[Music]
Mother Nature is can be vicious
absolutely Savage
[Music]
Falls now down to a tackle in places
I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake
close and personal with her
this is what makes the job
[Music]
well stock markets in the Asia Pacific
region had a largely positive session
overnight with both Hong Kong and
Shanghai finishing ahead by more than
one percent a piece that's ahead of a
raft of economic data this week the
Nikka in Tokyo meanwhile completed a
seventh consecutive game that's its
longest winning streak since July last
year Well in Europe stocks are largely
ahead this morning here's the picture
and Continental rip not many uh
individual features for investors to
hang their hats on this morning in
London the ftse 100 is also just about
in positive territory currently some 39
points to the good half of one percent
are that's on the back of games for some
of the mining heavyweights the leading
Blue Chip gainer in percentage terms
right now though is the distributor RS
group that shares up some two and a
quarter percent right now on broker
comment outside the ftse the industrial
Machinery maker Reynold is up 11 on a
trading update while the defense
Technology Group kinetic is ahead by
some four and a quarter percent that's
on news at profits for the year will be
better than expected meanwhile
International distribution services it
Shares are up some 5 sense that's after
its Royal Mail arm reached a pay deal
with the communication Workers Union
meanwhile Network International which I
mentioned earlier on there had 18 on
that takeover approach and Wood Group
which also mentioned earlier is ahead by
some seven percent for similar reasons
on the foreign exchange markets where
the US dollar has strengthened following
resilient retail sales figures that have
raised expectations of another U.S
interest rate rise next month the pound
is off by a quarter of one percent
against the dollar it's off by 10 to 1
against a single currency the Greek Euro
meanwhile also off by a quarter of one
percent against the Greenback as for the
oil price well after notching up another
week of gains last week it's a little
bit quieter this morning about a Brent
crude will currently set you back
85.92 cents a barrel that is off a
little on the half of one percent on the
session well joining me now is Ross mold
he's investment director at AJ Bell
Ruskin this morning a lot of interesting
bid situations around the mid caps right
now is this just because valuations are
so low I mean in the end valuation the
price you pay is the ultimate Arbiter of
investment return as long as you think
the business is pretty sound so the fact
that you've had a UK on the UK stock
market underperform for many years we've
discussed before and you still got a
currency that's below where it was in
June 2016 before the brexit vote so for
an overseas buyer that's an added bonus
it's an unload stock market can mean
undervalued unloved currency can mean
undervalued and that's what's attracting
the money and these bids I think are
both from private Equity companies out
there where we know there's still a lot
of money sloshing around absolutely
would you expect to see more takeover
activity in the mid cap sector I think
In fairness has been 12 300 companies
taking over since the brexit vote in
2016 Sky being one of them I seem to
remember a few years ago that was from
the first out of the traps it was arm
Shire sky went very quickly that others
have followed Ave Mega GKN not also
overseas buyers not also private Equity
buys but the majority of them so I
wouldn't be surprised in the slices
quite frankly fund managers may not be
very interested in UK equities but
somebody is and maybe that's a lesson
that we could learn absolutely well and
and certainly with uh lot of the trading
updates that we've had sparking some
quite High upward valuations yeah I mean
kinetic is an interesting example today
I mean they've had a a bit of a tricky
time there was one contract a big con
where they call it the complex contract
that cost them about 15 million pounds
they're still a bit Coy about who it was
with and where because they're still
working out a settlement but even if you
look through that underlying training
was actually pretty good and now they're
coming out of that trading very very
strong indeed again maybe reflection of
the times in which we live increasing
defense budgets increasing Global
Security concerns cyber security
concerns but it's in the right place at
the right time yeah now another one
that's caught your eye this morning an
update to page group The recruitment
company yeah this is interesting because
obviously employment numbers are still
looking incredibly good unemployment
rate very low in the UK very low in the
US even by European standards it's not
bad there either though much higher than
they would be here and it's just
intriguing to see that the big
double-digit percentage increases we saw
in fees last year they're these right
off so there's a slight drop in first
quarter fees year on year the company's
flagging a move preference that employs
the temporary rather than permanent
contracts which again reflects a bit of
economic uncertainty and some candidates
apparently holding off signing on the
dotted line so it just does suggest that
even one of the strongest economic
indicators we've had might be showing a
little bit of signs of weakness yeah now
later on today big event for the bond
market more uh developments on the U.S
debt ceiling yes speaker Kevin McCarthy
talking at the New York Stock Exchange
about the U.S debt ceiling
there's a settlement needed by June or
July and this is probably bringing back
some bad memories for Bond currency and
stock Traders from 2011 when there
wasn't a settlement reached and then
standard and post up the very brave
decision of downgrading U.S debt and I
think the down the day after promptly
fell six seven eight hundred points
would have one of its then worst days on
record so the political angle the
Republicans Democrats are setting up
their stall for November 2024 but
economically they won't want to do
something silly that means that the US
borrowing costs go higher because if
you've got 31.5 billion dollars in debt
as you do they're already paying 800
million dollars a year in interest and
that's when interest rates were really
low and now they're catching up your tax
incomes five trillion dollars so if your
interest rate keeps on going up then
that's less money for welfare or defense
so they are going to have to find a
solution yeah absolutely only 800
million like that sorry yes only good to
see Russ thank you
still to come here only in King life I'm
going to be speaking with the co-founder
and chief executive of coinbase about
the challenges still faced by the world
of crypto don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back our cryptocurrencies have
rallied this year with the price of
Bitcoin and ethereum almost doubling
since early January but it remains a
tough environment for crypto exchanges
since the collapse in November of FTX
the market leader binance is currently
being sued by the commodity Futures
Trading commission amid allegations it
has been operating illegally in the U.S
while its rival coinbase recently
announced is to cut a fifth of its
Workforce and it reached a 100 million
dollar settlement with New York
Regulators over anti-money laundering
failures which one I mean as Brian
Armstrong he's co-founder and chief
executive of coinbase Brian good to see
you this morning what sort of activity
have you seen on the exchange since
prices started to Rally well we have
seen a Resurgence in interest in crypto
as you mentioned I think you know
bitcoin's up almost 71 year-to-date
which is good and the perhaps the most
exciting thing about it though is that
we're still seeing a lot of developer
activity that to me is the most exciting
thing because you know trading is a big
use case for crypto but the potential of
it is much bigger than that it's really
a technology to update the financial
system in all in all aspects and then a
way for people to build new applications
on the internet which people are calling
web three so you know we're gonna that's
a long-term vision and we're committed
to getting that over a long period of
time what do you think's driven this
rallying crypto values
you know I always hate to sort of play
Monday Morning Quarterback and look back
and try to you know you know look a lot
of things the market came down interest
rates obviously is a factor I think some
of these Bank issues that we've seen
with svb and things like that have
caused people to sort of question you
know is the traditional Financial system
serving my needs or is there another
system that's outside of the you know
the banking system that people want to
actually hold some wealth in so that's
one reason but um you know the market is
very complex lots of participants you've
been very vocal on the need to improve
consumer confidence in the industry do
you think regulation is coming
I do in fact I mean the UK has been a
bit of a leader here I've been really
admiring the leadership from Rishi sunak
and the city Minister here um in London
and I think the UK I think five years
ago created this regulatory sandbox that
was actually very ahead of its time so
there's a lot more that needs to happen
in the UK but so far the the steps there
have been very positive
um in the U.S actually the US has been a
little bit of an outlier here it's been
not as forward leaning on on regulation
and we've spent a lot of time in DC I
have as well trying to make sure that
good comprehensive crypto legislation
gets passed in the U.S kind of like
we're seeing in in Europe with Mika a
lot of people would argue though that
how can you regulate an industry like
crypto when assets like Bitcoin ethereum
also deregulated there isn't a sort of
central player like the bank of England
or the Federal Reserve that can can sort
of hold things together yeah well I
think the centralized players in crypto
you know the exchanges the custodians
companies like coinbase those should be
regulated the decentralized aspects of
crypto which include you know Bitcoin
ethereum even this thing and defy those
should not be regulated not as financial
services at least right in my view
that's where we need to have a lot of
innovation but go regulate the
centralized players and a lot of the
best practices from traditional
Financial Services can be applied here
we don't need to reinvent the wheel you
know it's about having good customer
disclosures having audits you know
making sure no wash trading is happening
just basic Good Financial controls like
that that's what Mika's done and that's
what I think other countries are going
to do as well I think I mean you've
outlawed wash trading I think on the
platform haven't you of course yeah yeah
what about this Wells notice that you
received from the SEC recently when do
you expect to hear more on that right
well so just to give people background I
mean it's unfortunate we've we've spent
a long period of time really over the
last 10 months we spent maybe 30
meetings with the SEC never got any
feedback from them about what we could
be doing better even though we've asked
for it we filed a petition on it and of
course they even allowed us to become a
public company in the US you know so
they reviewed our business very
thoroughly during that process so it was
really disappointing to see this Wells
notice arrive and it's basically in the
U.S the SEC is creating this environment
of Regulation by enforcement you know
we've repeatedly asked them we just want
to have a clear rule book if you you
know publish the rules and we'll follow
them we'd be happy to but if there's not
a clear rule book why are there
enforcement actions arriving so anyway
the wells notice arrived I think we have
a chance to respond in maybe a week or
something like that and we'll see where
it goes but we're prepared to defend
ourselves in court we feel like we're
well within the rule of law and this is
about around your staking Services where
crypto assets are tied up um you're
going to carry on with that service
presumably well what's interesting is
the SEC has not actually even really
told us specifically what it's about
still to this to this date they've
mentioned in other meetings concerns
about staking and various other things
um but yeah we're planning to continue
our staking service and we feel very
confident it's not a security is that
something that's popular among among
users yeah it has been a popular service
I mean people want to find a way to
participate in staking services and it's
one of many aspects of where crypto can
kind of help update the financial system
now the last time we spoke which was
down the line was shortly after the
collapse of FTX how much of a headache
has that created for you in your
business
well I'd say in the US when I go to DC
it's still very top of mind for people
there because you know Sam was so
present in DC and some of them feel very
burned by it but outside of the US when
I meet with people in the UK or
Singapore or Hong Kong other Financial
hubs it doesn't FTX doesn't really come
up very much it mostly feels like that's
a distant memory people have turned the
page and in fact they're actually trying
to attract companies to come build in
those markets which I think is is the
right approach so yeah I think I would
like us to be able to turn the page on
that and the US needs to follow suit as
well but presumably it's good news too
in a sense in that it gives you an
opportunity to sort of come out and say
look we are we are completely different
we are not the same as those guys that's
right I mean that's what I did in the
weeks after it collapsed was just kind
of including speaking with you was to
reinforce that message to people and
um it's unfortunate there's a few bad
actors in crypto for sure I mean our
industry unfortunately has attracted
some folks like that but it gets a
disproportionate amount of headlines
compared to how many companies are
really building in a trusted and
legitimate way including coinbase
great to see you this morning thank you
thank you
foreign
have a lookout this morning's business
pages and the financial times leads its
print edition with the report that the
bank of England is considering a major
overhaul of its deposit guarantee scheme
which could include an increase in the
amount to which the deposits of business
customers are guaranteed the ft's
digital Edition meanwhile is currently
leading with a related story that Global
Regulators are considering imposing
tougher rules on smaller lenders and
requiring all banks to ready themselves
for faster runs on deposits well the
times leads its business pages with
criticism of the CBI for its decision to
turn to insiders to steer it through
misconduct allegations the paper also
reports that the power League Fiverr
side football chain has been put up for
sale by its private Equity owner with a
60 million pound price tag Daily
Telegraph meanwhile leads its business
pages with a report quoting research
that nearly half a million amateur
landlords are set to sell up during the
next five years as the baby boom
generation retires and Cashes in its
nest eggs the paper also reports that
the Welsh government has been stuck with
a portfolio of 31 homes that were
compulsarily purchased in order to make
way for a leaf Road near the Seven
Bridge and that road has since been
canceled
now today sees publication of the UK
Aviation industry's carbon road map in
which it sets out how it hopes to
achieve net zero emissions by 2050 well
Central to that will be greater uptake
of sustainable aviation fuel or saf
which is made of renewable waste and
residue raw materials like used cooking
oil it will also involve joining
Regional and international carbon
trading and offsetting schemes what
joining me now is the chair of the
sustainable Aviation Coalition Matt
Gordon Gorman Matt good to see you this
morning I mean the problem that we have
with saf in this country is we don't
have the sort of capability to make it
quickly enough it seems
uh well we don't yet but with the right
commitment by the industry and the right
action by government we're saying we
absolutely can so what we're launching
today is a clear plan to take the carbon
out of flying through efficiencies and
hydrogen as well as sustainable aviation
fuel but you're right sustainable
aviation fuel is about 40 of the
solution secondly we're saying it's not
just a decarbonization opportunity but
it's a huge Economic Opportunity for the
UK as well uh thousands of jobs billions
of investment possible but we are saying
uh that kind of opportunity is at risk
without urgent action by government so
the government said a great ambition for
jet zero what we now need is the
policies at speed because other
countries particularly the US are moving
ahead to corner of the market in these
Technologies now there's an implicit
cost in all of this both the industry
and for customers can you put a number
on it
uh well what we've said is that yes
there is some cost actually 75 percent
of our journey to Net Zero will happen
through some of these Technologies uh
within the sector uh but we're saying
that there's there's some cost and
actually we've built that into the
projections which show slightly lower
demand in future as a result of this
about 14 of our journey to Net Zero
comes through lower demand but actually
we're saying even with those costs
people still want to fly all of the
evidence shows people value flying
they're prepared to pay a bit more and
actually they'll be investing in these
green technologies of the future
you did mention uh demand there Mountain
the industry it's quite clear that the
extra costs are going to deter some
people from flying in future can you put
another figure on that perhaps
well we've always been open actually
that and clear as a sector that people
at the industry and ultimately
passengers should should pay the carbon
costs of their travel so as I said we're
saying if you look at our whole journey
to Net Zero 75 percent of that comes
from efficiency and sustainable aviation
fuel and hydrogen uh we're saying about
14 of it comes from slightly lower
demand in future and the rest is from
removing any carbon uh that's left but
the good news is all of the evidences
people value travel they're prepared to
pay a bit more and in paying a little
bit more they will be investing in these
green technologies of the future which
ultimately will let us take the carbon
out of flying so that we can carry on
enjoying what air travel brings us
wouldn't a better way of reducing
emissions be by more effective demand
management for example letting the train
take the strain on some short haul
Journeys instead of flying
well we think there's huge value in air
travel uh and it connects us around the
world support some of what we most enjoy
doing at you as humans you know
connecting exploring cooperating trading
around the world so we're saying look if
the technology is there to let us take
the carbon out why wouldn't we do that
particularly as it brings benefits to
the UK and what we're saying is
sustainable fuel efficiency hydrogen the
technology is there we've just got to
move quickly to scale it up
um you know in the UK uh yes uh where uh
train travel is competitive in terms of
time and cost people may well choose the
train but overall that won't substitute
some of the European and particularly
longer Journeys that we do all right
Matt got to leave it there appreciate
you joining me today thank you thank you
our recent advances by drug Giants such
as AstraZeneca in therapy areas such as
oncology have highlighted the importance
of so-called Precision medicine that's
tailoring a specific drug to individual
patient groups dependent on their
molecular or genetic makeup or
belfast-based diacutic supports this
work by supplying diagnostic testing
data to the drug developers today it
reported a 22 rise in fully pre-tax
profits to 564 000 pounds our sales Rose
by 40 to 19 and a half million pounds
we're joining me now is Nick Roberts
he's Chief Financial Officer at diacutic
Sir Nick welcome to you where's demand
for Diagnostic testing data strongest
right now
um yeah so we're finding it stronger in
the pharmaceutical sector and that's our
key customer base so we work with 21 of
the top 30 Global Pharma companies and
um 20 or 20 off the top Pharma companies
within Europe and the us and we're
finding that the biggest demand coming
from those Pharma customers is is around
oncology that's where we have
historically specialized in uh but are
looking to expand out into non-oncology
areas and rare diseases and we think
these are going to be some of the high
growth areas for precision medicine over
the coming decade or so where are the
therapy areas where it's hardest right
now to collect diagnostic data
yeah so we focus on collecting
diagnostic data from our unique lab
Network we capture that within our
platform and uh we we have this huge um
testing repository
um we think we've actually overcome the
challenges that we might see from some
of our competitors in collecting that
data because we have a very wide
collection of affiliate Labs that we can
tap into that's throughout the us where
we have a really strong robust supply
chain a growing supply chain throughout
labs in Europe and and again we have
good coverage we have excellent coverage
really in oncology but it's starting to
grow into other areas and these are
where we think it can be the high growth
areas in in the future so we think we've
managed to really secure our supply
chain through our unique lab Network
which has taken you know a good long
while to build that so when a former
client comes to you and says we'd like
this particular set of data what sort of
lead time do you require how quickly can
you turn around a request like that
very quickly so if we haven't got the
data ready it's it's it's most likely in
our repository and it's a case of asking
our data analytics team to work with
that and extract it so we can talk uh in
a matter of an hour or so to turn around
that data if we didn't have that data
for whatever reason that might be we
have this really strong lab Network we
can reach out to them and could turn
around and request within probably
within a matter of weeks and in terms of
how you get paid I noticed in the
statement today I think something like
35 percent of Revenue is now from
subscriptions presumably that is the way
that you'd like to take the business
yeah absolutely uh we've seen a huge
shift to subscription
um really driven postcoded by Farmers
propensity to to move to more digital
channels so they're quite welcoming at
the move to platform enabled and to
subscription it's gone up from three
percent in 2021 so 35 in 2022 we are
looking to invest in our strategy
actually accelerate our investment in
our strategy and one of the key things
that we want to see come out of that in
the end is is a higher proportion of our
Revenue which is subscription based
which gives us a lot more visibility and
stability over our revenues but also
multi-year so we've seen a nine-fold
increase in our order books from 1.7
million at the end of 2022 to
um over 16 so 16.9 million at the end of
uh of at the end of 2022 and that's
giving us really good visibility of
Revenue into future years
you spoke just now Nick about your your
lab testing Network around the world
what are the specific factors that would
lead you to use a specific site when
when you're dealing with a data request
is it all about patients in a certain
country or is there more to it than that
for a disease we want to have at least
60 patient coverage of that disease
within the geography whether that be
let's say a state in the U.S or a
country within Europe
um but of course we're looking to make
sure that we've got coverage in in all
of the right diseases so we will go and
pick Labs
um who are best serving the testing
needs we collect that data from those
labs and we can then pick those labs to
make sure that they're giving the right
data uh the right representation of the
testing landscape for Pharma to be able
to exploit and better commercialize
their medicines
um in the end getting better return on
investment for the uh the drug they're
launching now before I let you go you're
looking nice and relaxed this morning
but uh you've had I think 20 million
dollars worth on deposit with Silicon
Valley Bank when it went under last
month that you must have had a few
sleepless nights
uh no you're absolutely right there were
a few sleepless nights that weekend we
had a we had a large concentration of
our cast with SBB
um we finished our year at 19.8 million
in cash just really strong uh position
um we have very quickly pivoted uh to
introduce alternative banking
institutions we've Diversified our cash
now across those so we now have
alongside SBB and HSBC under one
umbrella we have another two tier one
financial institutions that we've now
deposited our cash reserves in so that
we have access to those just recognizing
that the banking sector still is going
through some trouble and we don't want
to be exposed to that any further all
right Nick gotta leave it there good to
see you this morning thank you
well we're going to go back to now what
we began the program with which is the
prime minister has been expanding on his
Ambitions for children to continue
learning maths in some form until
they're 18 we're listening to the speech
was our political editor Beth Rigby who
joins me now Beth uh how's the speech
gone down
well yeah we know that this is a very
numerate prime minister he worked in
hedge funds and in the city before he
went into politics he's a dab hand at
making a spreadsheet and he really
prizes numeracy and mathematical ability
and and the thrust of this speech was to
try and Cascade that if you like uh to
the whole of the country he talked about
maths being taught until between 16 and
18 so beyond GCC he said that didn't
necessarily mean kids needed to study
a-level maths but could they find a way
of making sure just with literacy that
numeracy became really core uh to
learning and he talked about a review in
which they're going to look how to do
that he talked about building more maths
hubs and he talked about uh more
qualifications for Primary School
teachers when it came to maths but look
the big elephant in the room there Ian
when he talked about this ambition for
maths is the reality of kids in state
schools across the UK he said it himself
that in England and Wales only a third
of children a third of children sorry
fail maths gcscs and we know that in
state schools in England and Wales
nearly half of maths teachers are
non-specialized in maths which really
goes back to the basics of education and
not about whether this is a cultural
issue which is what the Prime Minister
talked about about us being an
anti-maths mindset in this country but
rather was it a provision issue and he
acknowledged that the government needed
to do more and and make this a more
integrated policy but I think the sort
of ambition was there I think it's where
the rubber meets the road in terms of
the reality of what state school kids in
places like this in Islington in North
London are experience in the classrooms
and Beth obviously the PM's grappling
with some very uh heavy public sector
strikes particularly in the NHS has he
had anything to say on that this morning
well exactly and then that was another
area of questions there's already been
uh six teachers strikes uh this year a
couple more planned and as you said uh
the Royal College of nurses say that
their members have not accepted the
government's payoff and now there is the
prospects of T nurses strikes running uh
into Christmas the Prime Minister
obviously asked about that he says he's
disappointed
um that uh public sector workers haven't
accepted the deals but hopes to find a
way through but I'm afraid in for now no
more detail all right Beth thanks for
that much more on that story coming up
throughout the morning here on Sky News
after this it's Jane second to stay
tuned I'll join you at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning Julia
foreign